dr disrespect has finally broken his
silence
in regards to his twitch ban but we
still don't know
exactly the reason he was banned in the
first place
so i'm here today to analyze everything
that's happened so far
and the pensive and reserved way he's
answering questions
and try to figure out just what the hell
that video he posted
really means let's get into this
[Music]
okay so before we get into all this dr
disrespect stuff i've got to remind you
to give us a follow
over at twitch.tv slash the score
esports when this doc news first broke
we actually went live
on our talk show clouded to talk about
the news and break it down on twitch
so if you don't want to miss that kind
of stuff or any of the other cool stuff
we're doing on twitch
make sure you're following so like many
of esports's greatest mysteries
this whole situation started with one
slash retweet
and he's of course known for breaking
news in the gaming and streaming world
on june 26
at 4 22 pm eastern time slasher tweeted
that dr disrespect
had been banned from twitch permanently
and so given the fact that doc is one of
the biggest streamers on the planet
and he hadn't walked into any bathrooms
recently
people were understandably shocked of
course this all happened amidst the slew
of sexual assault allegations that have
been happening in the esports and gaming
world over the last month or so
i actually did a video trying to compile
all the parts of that story last week
naturally as the news cycle works doc
got caught up in that and people were
speculating on twitter that his band
could be related which to me is kind of
like the natural way of twitter
drawing comparisons when there's nothing
to go off of but as far as i'm concerned
it's a pretty unfair position to put doc
in
with absolutely zero information about
the subject
a lot of people were also speculating
about doc's last stream
and how sort of eerie and unnerving
those last few minutes were
david ike i ordered this book too
i appreciate everyone watching today
we'll get through this champions club i
know it's a tough that's
because life's weird right now all right
[Music]
[ __ ] now that clip coupled with his
strange tangent about conspiracy
theorist david ike
someone who's been accused of being
anti-semitic for years
led some people to believe that this
could just be a symptom of twitch's
three strikes in your out rule doc's
been banned before and now speaking
about someone who's been accused of
anti-semitism in the past
well maybe this was just the final
strike in twitch's eyes
something that our very own colin mcneil
brought up when we were talking about
the situation a couple weeks ago on our
talk show clothing
basically doc in the last little part of
his last stream
was talking about how he watched a
netflix documentary on a gentleman
called david ike
and then he then doc proceeded to
kind of um paint david ike in a
in in a favorable light and say
things to the effect of you know it's
about expanding your mind or looking at
truth or waking up
and he's kind of cool you should check
him out and i bought his book
and i liked his documentary and i kind
of digged the guy right it was along
those lines and then there was the
strangely obvious guess that this could
all be a publicity stunt
because let's be real here that's
completely in doc's range
there is no [ __ ] way that this is a
publicity stunt
like let me just say that again there's
no [ __ ] way like
to do this at this time
in the social zeitgeist with the
movements that are
happening now would be the worst
calculated marketing
ploy in recent memory with all
speculation aside the coming days after
slasher's original tweet
really made this feel a lot more severe
than your average twitch band
i mean let's be real here it's my job to
pay attention to who gets banned on
twitch
but this felt a little different than
your average terms of service violation
just a day later on june 27th
news began to circle that doc's
subscribers were being refunded
his discord partnership had been revoked
and his wife
finally made a statement on her
instagram thanking his supporters
and in case you didn't know normally
when someone gets banned on twitch
they don't go so far as to start
refunding subscribers
that's kind of out of the ordinary there
were also reports that docs and moats
were unable to be used in twitch
channels
and twitch staffers were being told to
go back through their social media
archives
and delete all the references to dr
disrespect remember this is a guy that
signed a
massive multi-million dollar contract to
stream exclusively on twitch
just a few months ago
to my recollection there have only been
a few other bands on twitch that have
been handled this way where they're
literally refunding subscribers
we're talking names like ice poseidon
zillion op
and phantom lord who are basically the
upper brass of being permabanned on
twitch
now while all this was going down doc
stayed quiet on all platforms
until around 10 pm on june 27th when he
tweeted this
champions club twitch has not notified
me on the specific reason behind their
decision
firm handshakes to all for the support
during this difficult time
doctor disrespect notably the fact that
doc wasn't
notified by twitch about the specific
reason as to why he was banned
doesn't mean that he doesn't have any
theories often people
get notified that they violate tos when
they get banned from twitch
but they don't get told the specific
reason why you see it on twitter all the
time
streamers who got banned and they're
basically guessing the reason for the
ban
i mean it could be a good thing or a bad
thing but it's been going on like this
for years
and so that's how this whole situation
started one of twitch's biggest names
banned
and everyone looking to twitter slasher
and doc for an explanation
but all they actually found was this
slasher has claimed that he knows the
reason for the ban
but due to a fear of putting his sources
in a bad position
and trying to figure out the full story
before he says anything
he hasn't shared it with us which again
and this is coming from someone who is
also a reporter cause people to believe
that this could be a pretty severe issue
i mean slasher breaks like
a lot of news something would have to
really go wrong for him to not want to
share it
and during that first wave of news
that's pretty much all we got as far as
understanding this doc situation
until this week when the topic of
slasher finally revealing that
information resurfaced on hassan's
stream where he was a guest
and he said that he was looking for
legal indemnity
from a media outlet so that he could
publish it i don't want to put it
personally
on twitter and i do need a publication
to back me but this requires indemnity
that i want and that has been rather
difficult
to acquire and that means that i get
legal protection
from uh the outlet that i publish for so
yes
a defamation suit um is very
is that the high point of concern for me
and other journalists
basically he told hassan that the
situation was pretty murky
and for fear of legal repercussions he
was looking for a media outlet to
protect him legally as a freelancer
in exchange for letting them publish the
information and that was a topic that we
also talked about over on twitch on
clouded this week what slasher is saying
he's looking for indemnity which
indemnity means like legal protection
basically
essentially not like a basically what
he's saying is that i want an
outlet whatever that it might be to have
their legal team
be ready to have a defense for me
essentially or for us as the entity
publishing
slasher also alleged that twitch has
undergone their own investigation
to find out who leaked the information
to him in the first place
like i can say from what i've heard
twitch has been doing
a massive internal investigation since
everything happened the day that i
reported that dr respect was permanently
bad
and then just yesterday doc broke his
silence again
when he decided to do brief interviews
with both the washington post
and pc gamer both interviews basically
include the same
carefully crafted statements but i'm
going to read some of those for you now
he stayed pretty consistent with the
fact
that twitch has not identified to him
what the reason for his ban was when he
was talking to the washington post
quote honestly we just don't know it was
a total shock
imagine showing up to work and the doors
are closed and you can't get inside
you're going what's going on and you've
been told that you've been fired
but you haven't been told the reason why
we just weren't given an answer
it was the worst feeling end quote and
when asked by pc gamer about all the
speculations regarding the reason for
his ban
he said quote listen i'm not interested
in engaging crazy speculation
i've seen all the theories i've seen all
the possible conspiracies
and it's just like i'm just not
interested in engaging that type of
stuff
i have a great community of loyal fans
and i'm totally focused on getting back
and delivering great
entertaining content and that's where
the focus is end quote
maybe the most staggering part of both
interviews happened when pc gamer
reporter steven messner asked him about
his recent on-stream antics and his
comments about david ike
doc started to answer the question but
then was immediately cut off by his
publicist
who said quote we're getting really
close to dangerous territory here
so you know doc we don't know why twitch
banned him and there is no formal
warnings or reprimand on record
that's all legal is going to let him say
end quote doc
also confirmed during the interview that
his exclusive contract to stream on
twitch has ended and that he's exploring
options for streaming on platforms like
youtube or facebook
or even on his own website which to me
was pretty surprising
because up until this point all we've
gotten from doc is like
radio silence so the idea of him ever
streaming again
started to feel pretty unlikely when all
this first started a streamer named
shannon z killer on twitter tweeted this
out
suggesting that doc was not only done on
twitch but done everywhere that tweet
has since been deleted so given those
initial reactions
for me i was like is doc ever gonna
stream again
but then yesterday in traditional doc
fashion
he gave us the kind of teaser that
suggests
we'll probably see him again
one minute and eight seconds a
silhouette him in an
alley and a sports car and all of a
sudden it feels like
dr disrespect is gearing up for a return
after weeks of not hearing from him i
mean look at the replies to this tweet
some of twitch's most famous
personalities are literally cheering him
on
in the midst of a massive uncertain
controversy
this doc roller coaster never really
seems to end so there you have it
everything we know up until this point
about dr disrespect's
abrupt permanent ban from twitch so what
do you guys think
is doc the streamer that never dies is
he impossible to get rid of
is this all just one big publicity stunt
that fooled us all
including us at the score esports let us
know in the comments
all right guys so colin's been doing
this thing where he takes you through
all this nerdy [ __ ] on his bookshelves
during end boards
so i figured i would do it i get a lot
of comments about
the shoes in my background everyone out
there big
hypebeast loving my shoe collection a
lot of things about
jordan ones about the off-whites about
the breads
but today i'm giving you a review a
little bit of a review
the best shoe of 2019 new balance
no bad days doesn't get enough love
got lots of materials we got leather we
got colors
you know sparks imagination sparks joy
sparks devin
look all i'm saying is in the world of
in the world of shoe people
there's a lot of talk about yeezys and
jordan ones and off wood and virgil
and [ __ ] jerry lorenzo and [ __ ] but
bodega no days off or no bad days
new balances best shoe of 2019.